hey it's good to see you guys good to
see you guys back by the way
thanks yeah hey good to see you too good
to be back
i know your fans were just like waiting
and waiting just dying to see anything
from you guys for the last few months
what was it like i mean people are
calling it a hiatus but you guys were
working
you guys were working really hard just
changing just a change of pace what was
it like
after touring and touring and being in
the middle of everything to kind of like
ghost all social media and just buckle
down and work on this thing
wow it was i mean
so at first it was a little weird i
won't lie um
because like you said we came off of
touring for
like three years straight and and last
year in 2019 we put out a song every
month and so we were like in everybody's
face and
we were used to being in everybody's
face and always in a new place
and whatever whatever so it was weird
at first um but it was also good because
we took the first couple months
um to kind of just chill out for a
second and
you know regain that that drive and kind
of you know
our mottos always work hard play hard
and um so we kind of you know
didn't like play hard but playing hard
in that sense was like you know
jonah went to go see his family and uh
we were hanging out with family out here
in la
and whatnot and then come like
man i don't remember when it actually
was but there was a time where we were
like all right time to kick into gear
let's get this album pumping
um and then covet happened and so the
whole process kind of got shifted
um but i think uh silver lining of that
is that if we didn't have the extra time
because of the pandemic
um we would not have had fallen uh which
was the last song that we wrote for the
album which is kind of ironic
um yeah can you tell us how like
how fallen happened like who was the
first person to be like i've got
like a seed of something we gotta make
this a song um so
yeah i actually was uh on my way to the
studio
we were working on a song for the album
uh it was
it wasn't falling um but we were working
on a separate song
and on the way to the studio the melody
for fallen kind of dropped into my head
just the whole pass through the song so
i recorded it on my voice memos
ran into the studio pulled out my laptop
made a little loop of the beat
just super simple um and brought it to
the guys and
sang it for him on the loop and right
away corbin and jonah were like
let's go write this this is special ran
into a room
wrote it in about an hour which is
really quick for us because we usually
are pretty
uh perfectionistic with all of our music
perfectionist
perfectionistic with all of our music um
but this one just was it was it was
different it was magical it literally
fell into our heads
like a gift from god and it was uh yeah
done in an hour
no changes were made which is also rare
for us that we don't go back and change
anything
um it was just done and perfect we just
put out like a webisode too
on youtube uh of the making of fallen
and at the very end it's
the last 30 seconds of the video um
is is actually the voice memo of him
singing it in his car on the way to
the studio and uh the melody's a little
bit different now in the actual song
uh but you can hear the foundation of
where that melody came from
in the voice memo and it's it's a cool
little look inside
um you know his mind before the song
actually was written
wow so all those unique circumstances is
that part of what makes this
like the perfect comeback single you
know
yeah i wasn't really thinking about it
like that but yeah i think
there was some magic to fall in that
like yeah falling was a gift
from the heavens yeah yeah it's so
special
i mean the thing was the whole album is
very bouncy
very energetic there's some slow songs
and it's all
you know it's all special but we didn't
really have that one
intro song that tied everything together
and that's what falling was
for this album right now
there's a saying that goes like you have
your whole life to make your debut album
of five minutes to make your second
like your follow-up yeah and there's
like there's a bit of pressure there
somehow too like do you guys
do you guys feel that do you agree with
that statement well
you know in a weird way this to me this
album will be
oddly enough our debut as songwriters
and producers
because in the past we uh we you know we
helped write the music to an extent but
that wasn't our melodies or lyrics for
the most part and you know we
we loved every song that we came out
with and would only come out with the
song that we emotionally could attach to
or we
like the melody of and blah blah blah
but this is our
you know first time really giving the
fans
our true honest melodies and lyrics and
production
and um so yeah i think it's going to be
you know
exciting for them to hear us and just
fully 100 us how does that change your
approach
to the idea of performing because like
like you said you love everything you
put out before but now there's got to be
an added sort of
i don't say stress or pressure but
certainly an added emotion to it because
these are your
words your music yeah um
i mean i'm i'm honestly really really
excited uh kind of going off of what
daniel said this music is the most
us our music has ever been um and
you know there's there's a story uh we
were in
i think this was last july um
we were in atlanta uh doing some promo
and and i was just like laying in my bed
and i was like i wonder what's going on
in atlanta tonight uh
and shawn mendes was playing a show at
the arena there um and so we hit his
team up and
they graciously uh come to us some
tickets and we were there got to watch
the whole show it was fantastic and uh
we met up with him afterwards and um
he just gave us some great advice about
um you know following our own path and
like choosing our own destiny
um and you know we were talking to him
and he didn't even know that we all
played instruments at the time
and you know that was like a big key for
us because we all have been playing
instruments for years
uh but we've just never incorporated it
you know 100
into our music or into our live show and
um i just remember him telling us like
if you all want to play instruments and
do that for your show you guys should do
that for your show
um and we were like i mean yeah um
yeah so it was very like you know it
felt like early on there's
in a sense almost this mold that you had
to fit yeah um
you know us being who we are it just
felt like we had to
you know we had to dance we had to sing
certain five guys in a band
and you know honestly our fans were the
people that really
brought it to our attention that we
should start
listening to our own gut a bit more um
and god we have the best fans in the
world for that because the difference
of the music and even the live show that
we're already working on is
insane it's like we've really come into
our own shelter
we've broken ourselves yeah you know and
we're really who we're supposed to be
now
so is that what defines this new era
that you guys are talking about this you
guys just being yourselves
yeah yeah i think um you know there was
a lot of
i wouldn't say censorship before um
but you know with with fitting a certain
mold
um and it worked out so far and i
wouldn't trade any of that
any of what we've ever done in the past
for the world um
but you know and i feel like in every
artist's career there's
there's like a shift in momentum and
direction
and um and i i
i know that that that this time right
now is that for us
um and i really think the fans are gonna
love it it seems like they already are
which is really great um yeah i think we
were taking
the whole um idea of music a bit too
serious in the past too and we're at
this point where we're like
music is music man like it shouldn't it
shouldn't be over thought
and it you know it should be about just
that like feeling you get when you love
it and that's what this whole album is
yeah right on now you know four years
does that feel like a fast time to you
guys or does it feel like
a long time to you guys because i'm sure
at times it feels like you've been doing
it forever but
when you look back on four years it's
like this right yeah
yeah it's and it's it's an odd mix of
both
um because when you're having fun time
really flies
and we have done so much together
um that like there's there's too many
memories to even remember
and so like you know yesterday i woke up
and i was just
because it was our four year anniversary
yesterday and i just woke up and i was
just like
man we've done a lot of stuff together
but like
here we are today and four years have
have flown by and like
where did the time go like we've been to
you know we've done two world tours and
before that
we did two headlining and we've done
jingle ball three times and like
it's just so many shows and so many
things that it's it's been
yeah it's been fast but like you know
there have been some long days for sure
yeah like among all that obviously
there's a lot of opportunity for you
guys to have
um amazing experiences together and
great times but also a lot of
opportunity for friction right like
what do you say keeps you guys so in
sync and working together so well
man keeping us together the way we have
been this close it got to be jesus or
something man i don't get it
it honestly blows my mind how
well we get along and it might be the
fact that we've
you know really started from the bottom
of
the bottom together and i think maybe
it's just the fact that
we've always been in like a level
playing field in that sense that maybe
we
just like never have over thought it but
man we just we really don't fight i
think none of us
even like want to fight half the time
and we
usually don't have the time or energy to
fight because we're usually so damn busy
but we don't really fight yeah yeah
and you said a little bit earlier that
you guys had
time to spend with your families during
that time you guys like
were off tour and all that um with
regards to jack who do you think he
would pick as like the best babysitter
for his baby girl
um i would think jonah would probably be
the best babysitter for love
yeah jonah just just uh got a little
bingo kitty too
so he's kind of in dad mode right now
me and corbin i feel like would be like
the most fun for lab like oh yeah
the most enabling like yeah yeah
and like probably not once until
yeah it would be dope and like zach
probably shouldn't
just like on his own babysit lap yeah or
anything
you guys like the cool uncles you're the
two cool uncles i think i think we'll be
that
i would like to be that for that i'll
take the title and run with it
right on
you